ils ont l'esprit de modification en
général ces trois secondes deux secondes
pour donner les devants mais c'est de
pouvoir le faire sans la calculatrice
parce que au niveau de la commission
régionale du corps arbitral de
martinique nous avons mis en place un
plan de formation en 2018 avec d'amour
une formation d'arbitré régional que
nous avons fait
au mois de juin donc c'est moi qui l'ait
fait en tant que formateur nous avons eu
11 candidats avec 8 qui ont été reçus
une bonne combustion arbitre régional on
commence par ce niveau là certains
étaient déjà en orbite le club donc
avait déjà un petit niveau d'arbitrage
et puis après nous avons
continuer avec riz blanc pour lambert ne
sont autorisés que dans les épreuves du
calendrier 15 juillet avant le tour de
martinique nous avons fait une formation
de juges à l'arrivée ensuite le 5
juillet nous avons commencé la formation
de chronométreur régionales ça c'était
avant le tour de martinique ensuite
c'était le tour de martini après le tour
de martinique donc hier c'était le 17
nous avons fait une formation de
commissaires moto ensuite aujourd'hui
nous faisons le 18 9 dont la deuxième
journée de la formation de
kohno métro régional et nous ferons
l'examen de chronomètre régionales
vendredi donc la fédération nous signé
aussi sur les épreuves d'outre-mer pour
aller former les arbitres on peut
s'apercevoir que quelques pratiques sont
un peu différentes de ce qui peut se
passer en métropole mais l'important
c'est qu'on puisse arriver à une
uniformisation de toutes les
et pratique je dirais de l'arbitrage
aussi bien j'y arrive et chronométreurs
et arbitres titulaire noté beaucoup de
beaucoup de jeunes arbitres avec un
désir d'apprendre curieux de toutes les
pratiques
on peut dire que l'homme est passé je
l'espère fortement
moi je vous dis il ya certainement des
choses à revoir peut-être en
retravaillant avec les gaiters quand il
faut près des directeurs sportifs auprès
des clubs aussi de façon à apporter je
dirais une connaissance et non pas
continuer dans des pratiques qui sont
pas toujours les bonnes au niveau des
directeurs sportifs